tell you a little story in fact it's
quite a big story i kind of dated a
tinder swinner in the first lockdown and
this story is gonna
it's gonna send your mind a little bit
wild
did he ask him for 80 000 because his
enemies uh
close close very very close so this guy
i matched on tinder with i think like
2018 and he'd been kind of you know
messaging me for a while and to be
honest i looked at his instagram and i
thought this guy's fake he is too
beautiful to be real there's no way this
man is real you got a reverse image
search
he is not real right anyway he he
started messaging me again and we got
chatting and it was literally the
beginning of like 2020 end of 2019 so i
agreed to meet him and we went on a date
and i was like oh my god he's actually
real but he'd been a little bit funny in
messages like a little bit arrogant and
i was like yeah i'm not digging your
vibe you may be pretty but your brain is
not that great so why'd you go and see
him because i thought i'd give him a
chance because he really was pursuing me
this has been going on for two years so
i thought okay give give this guy a go
so he went for a drink and he told me
that his mom had a charity in africa and
everything like this and you know that
really you know when someone does
something for the community i thought
okay this guy's pretty good
anyway
it all happened very fast lockdown
happened and um we ended up moving in
together which was the the biggest
mistake ever
wait you moved after how long okay i'm
not gonna lie like four weeks he decided
to like move
okay all right okay
i've been there move on okay
so anyway anyway this this this kind of
happened you got what you deserve
yeah you got what you deserve no no no
no no no no no four weeks
it happened because we were both in a
financial situation where i was gonna
have to go back to jersey and he was
gonna have to go back to wherever he
lived i don't even know this man i don't
even know if he's real like his name is
really his name so we ended up together
because of the situation not because
we're like oh yeah we love each other so
much let's live together because of the
situation we knew we liked each other we
were sexually attracted to each other
and we knew we got on can i just say you
don't move in
with anyone yeah if there's not that
element of what you just said no i get
that but it was a scary time wasn't it
at the beginning of lockdown nobody knew
what was going on like financially like
emotionally and i was living on my own
he was living at a hotel so we ended up
together okay now during the course of
this relationship a lot of weird things
started going on he started telling me
about this friend of his marie who lived
in dubai she was an air hostess and you
know she she was really sweet and it was
so great babe yeah she's got in contact
with me i'm going to go and see her it's
amazing we're childhood friends from
paris now i can keep up with these
stories okay because he was born in
brazil then he was born in cameroon then
he was born in paris and i was like i
don't know bro like where are you kirsty
curtis you're living with this guy yeah
and his story changes from cameroon to
brazil or brazil to cameroon yeah it
goes very complicated yeah but what what
what what is your reaction at least okay
so he started going off we gotta break
this
i was so down
so confused so he kept moaning at me
that i wasn't commenting on his photos
on instagram and i was like why do i
need to comment babe like i'm right here
with you would you not i'd rather give
you affection here is it no it's my life
you need to comment on my on my pictures
all the time
no no no listen so i knew something was
going on so i commented once on a photo
right and then and then it exploded
my dms with girls
a girl first of all messaged me and
apparently he was in a relationship with
her and had been for six months an
online relationship she got so mad she
set up five fake instagram accounts she
released all his naked photos and videos
told these women to get in contact with
me
the 300 and whatever woman he was
following told them to message me and my
inbox was flooded with messages like oh
my god he's been like so why not why did
he want you to comment i have no idea
was he trying to get rid of you loki
like he was he was trying to get us to
move to france in this fake house that
apparently his dad had that didn't exist
like percy can i just say
you got given multiple red flags
literally you got given multiple red
flags i mean each red flag you acted
like an ostrich and you buried your head
in the sand right and so
there are too many women out there yeah
that's it right no you just have to take
us i'd take accountability i'm just
saying
when a guy says to you he was born in
cameroon but then all of a sudden he's
born in brazil yeah he's changed
you're going to be like
i had some wine at the time i didn't
know what was wrong
did i dream it like
the other problem is that you also could
have been in fear because of the
situation you were in you said it
yourself that yeah was it hot how hot
was he
feeling oh i'm going to show you how let
me let me see
pull up his ig on the screen
now watch this now watch this now watch
this right
the fact that she was like how hot he is
yeah
still shows me he still shows me that
you still have a little bit of that
twinkle for you no no no i promise you
you swear down i'm thinking that
someone's attractive without wanting
yourself so he
just to put things in perspective what
he did was he would set his hinge and
tinder to different jurisdictions in the
world so every month when his benefit
ran out because he was claiming benefit
in loads of different jurisdictions
he had a child as well he couldn't
remember that's right so he'd meet women
in different jurisdictions and then find
his next place to live
oh my god and then he told all these
women that he lost like ten thousand
fifteen thousand same sub story my my
flat um my roommate my friend his his
house
and i lost my laptop all my designer
clothes my rolex my money and he told
the same story to these three hundred
people
at least they didn't get cash out of you
women do disguise all the time
the only reason why the tinder swindler
was the story is because guys don't
generally do this type of stuff they
don't generally swindle women out of
their money women are swindling men out
of their money for those down women
aren't dumb enough yeah that's true
that's true
a lot of our money most
men are just more like they have more
we're speaking french because i don't
know who we is it's not gonna be me
wait let me see let me see
i was like he has to be like
crazy good looking to get away with this
there's no way actually he's actually
homeless this guy but you look at him i
understand and he goes and he goes
i had to take photos of him outside
houses and he was pretending that
honestly i can't i can't
but i i came this is proof folks that
instagram really does not show you [ __ ]
right instagram really does not show you
[ __ ] like
yeah
man look like you live in the time of
his life and oh no he's not homeless
yeah so the thing is right
um women are attracted to attracted to
shiny things uh-huh okay
and what you got shown there's a shiny
thing
very shiny
diamonds
and the thing is men that understand
that women get attracted to shiny things
can exploit that just like women that
understand men get attracted to women
right or their ass or their boobs or
their whatever can attract a guy like
that yeah but i'll be completely honest
i found him super boring right i'll be
completely honestly attractive people
are born super boring i'm not boring he
would he would have about me because he
was like i can hear you on the phone
your guy makes you laughing you're going
to leave me you get like really you know
worked up about it but i would not have
been with him had it not been for the
pandemic there's no chance in how i
would have continued dating him it was
just how long how long were you living
with him for three months about three
months yeah
three months you're with this guy yeah
the same every day
every day and he was just honest and
you've only known it for four weeks
yeah yeah i know
you don't look at it
look at it look at it she's agreeing
she's not about kissing like
this obviously you've learned from your
experience don't kick her while she's
down sorry she admitted to it it was a
bad time okay okay fair enough
financially emotionally
she was there yeah
so if i ever get homeless i know who i'm
calling
one thing you didn't realize is that
she's learned from it yeah
did you go pick some other dumb broad
so you think you wouldn't do it again
well make this mistake with him
with a different guy
i mean
the fact that it was i mean is already a
problem
this is